in 2022 outer space grew clearer bigger
and a bit safer for the scientists
studying it from Earth
in a year of dramatic discoveries
astronomers captured images of the
oldest known star the furthest known
planet orbiting another Sun
the black hole at the center of our
galaxy
and details from the surface of our own
Sun
the number of people living in space
grew China now has a permanent home in
orbit 24 years after the launch of the
International Space Station
but two missions shattered targets the
first literally the half-ton Dart
satellite slammed into a 160 meter wide
asteroid called dimorphos at six
kilometers per second it was a test of
an earth-saving defense system and it
worked the shimmering debris thrown up
by the impact was captured by
observatories around our planet
but nothing was as spectacular as the
first images from the James Webb Space
Telescope to the Edge of Time itself
more than 20 years in the making 14
years late the world's largest
space-based telescope flew one and a
half million kilometers and looked at a
point in the sky smaller than a grain of
sand held at arm's length that grain
contained a myriad of stars
Webb's first picture revealed the oldest
and furthest objects human eyes have
ever seen ancient galaxies at the
visible edge of the universe now these
tiny dots of color are helping to fill
in the picture of how everything began
the image provoked more questions we are
looking as far back as currently humanly
possible and that is our goal is to keep
trying to study further and further back
so that we can understand better the
time in Cosmic history that we've only
been able to really theorize Webb's
astronomers spotted water carbon
monoxide and gases that volcanoes
release into atmospheres of planets far
beyond our sun one system orbiting a sun
known as trappist-1 looks tantalizingly
similar to our own so now we have kind
of our first chance at studying another
star system that has a bunch of small
rocky planets to say okay how different
are they what does that mean about their
potential for supporting life
and astronomers used web to make
discoveries much closer to home when I
saw the first image of Neptune we
I actually started to cry
ing for over 30 years and to see this
planet again like that um what I saw
first and foremost was the ring system
of Neptune the last time we had seen it
was in 1989 when the Voyager spacecraft
Flew Over the cloud tops of Neptune in
2023 Webb will study hundreds of new
targets and probes will reach new
asteroids that says India aims for a
lunar landing and Europe plans a mission
to the icy moons of Jupiter Colin Baker
Al Jazeera